about 8 percent of clark county
residents are fully vaccinated this
according to the department of health
and human
services while we are beginning week 13
of the state's vaccination
efforts the i-team's vanessa murphy has
some basics
on what nevadans need to know she is
live in the digital center with more
vanessa brian some misinformation has
been trickling in and we want to provide
some clarification for
our viewers now one reminder is no one
should be paying
any out of pocket costs for the covid 19
vaccine if someone calls you
asking for payment information do not
provide it
the state has warned nevadans before
scammers are trying to take advantage of
people during the pandemic
according to candice mcdaniel who heads
the state's vaccination efforts even if
your health insurance information is
collected at a vaccination site
you still should not pay any
out-of-pocket costs
the insurance might be billed for an
administrative fee like through a
pharmacy as an example
but there is no out of out of pocket
cost whatsoever
another concern we've heard is the issue
of identification
and whether you need a nevada id like a
driver's license
to get vaccinated here mcdaniel tells me
an individual would not be turned away
if they do not have a nevada id
you will need to present id at the
vaccination site
so the dose can be reported but there is
no requirement
that it has to be from nevada and we
have more information about
booking appointments other issues at
eight newsnow dot com nevada 211 is also
a resource we have that information here
up on the web
but of course you can call 2-1-1 they
can help you book an appointment it's a
great resource
for anyone having trouble doing that
online or who may not have
internet access again that's nevada211
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now